[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are entering into the home
stretch
of sex timber you caught us in the
middle of sex uh kind of sex timber
you're walking in on
well hopefully you're not
hopefully exactly hopefully you've been
here the whole time we've been talking
about sex yeah if you haven't go back
yeah start at the beginning you could
listen to this on its own but really you
need to go back to part one this is part
four that uh what we thought we thought
it was gonna be part three but part two
just got so
big and long
that it turns sometimes i'm sorry i
don't don't try so hard i'm not trying
you're trying to i'm not trying at all
i'm not planning any of this it just
comes out you're kind of forcing it uh
this is a very special episode because
we are actually going to uh at some
point if we can figure out the technical
side of things we're having a little
issue with that but i think we will uh
have jesse and christy join us via
satellite
it's what it seems like we want to get
rid of just uh just like a call because
we're talking about the
well
we're going to talk about the first time
that i had sex the first time you had
sex
uh which is all also the first time that
our wives had sex yeah and i you know
i'll just go ahead and give the
disclaimer shorter version of our normal
disclaimer hey we're just
we're talking about our experiences
they're actually very narrow experiences
in the
in the realm of
people's sexual development and
so we just want to acknowledge that once
again we're two straight white cis dudes
who've been married uh once
and had sex only within the context of
that marriage
we
are speaking from that perspective and
we're not representing anybody else's
perspective but we absolutely
acknowledge that there are so many
different experiences
that
listeners are bringing to this thing and
especially when it comes to the topic of
coming out of purity culture and
assessing the impact that that had on us
is not a blanket statement about the
impact it had on anybody else but we are
expanding that perspective a little bit
today by having our wives be a part of
the conversation
um
but yeah so we'll talk about that first
time and then we're gonna get in some
different questions with our wives uh
everything from
what was it like for them to be
you know
finally be able to be sexually active in
the in the context of kind of coming up
through this purity culture we're going
to talk a little bit about parenting
as our views have changed over time i'm
going to talk about what if we can get
to it we'll talk about you know how do
you maintain a sexual relationship a
vibrant sexual relationship after 22
decades of being 22 decades 20 to two
decades uh 20 years of being married to
the same person
so 200 years we'll uh we'll get into
that what it feels like to you because
it's as fresh as a newborn baby to me
what why are you trying to speak for me
man
i'm just in i'm just kidding
i'm just joking man um but yeah but
let's so before we bring the ladies in
we are going to
talk about our
like what our perspective on it was for
each of us
that one night at the uh
where was i
did we stay at the same hotel like a
year apart you got married a year before
me but
it was that hotel next to the airport no
i didn't i didn't i don't think it's
romantic to hear planes flying over i
stayed at like a
residence inn no my mine was uh
the really nice hotel i mean i'm gonna
say near the airport i just mean it's on
that side of town but it was like i
think i stayed there because you were
like oh the place that you should stay
before you travel to mexico
on your honeymoon is because you went to
jamaica i went to mexico
is this what is it i thought it was
called a residence inn maybe it is i
made residence there just for for one
night one night i mean you i i since i
went first maybe i should go first sure
let's hear it so yeah i managed to stay
a virgin
until
my wedding night
um as i chronicled last week we you know
once christie and i got engaged
we started making out we started we we
then began a physical relationship and
it was kind of like that aspect of our
relationship caught up with all the
other aspects of our relationship that
have been developing at more of
what some people might consider more of
a normal pace but we had really cordoned
off this area in the name of
purity and in service to god and not
making past mistakes that i had made
to
to just to wait
because we were in true love and you
know what true love does it waits
um
but it wasn't it was an issue of
integrity and i think that's something
that we will go back to and
maybe all of you guys can speak to as
well that like
i'm still i'm proud of the fact that we
waited until we were married to have sex
because that's what we that was those
were our convictions at the time
and
we followed through with that but
it was
it was very very difficult
and there was a lot of build up so just
as much as
and christy and her family was planning
the wedding and like all the details of
that
i was i was along for the ride when it
came to that and i was like yesing and
yes ending all of that but i was
thinking
the reaction is really in the wedding
night not the wedding day you know what
i'm saying it's like that's what i'm
really looking forward to and is it so
built up that it's going to go sideways
well you know i have a way of there's no
having these expectations if it goes
sideways that doesn't mean there's
nothing wrong with you
there's
all penises
are normal penises
go up some gum down some go left some go
right
and i would say what mine does but i
don't want to then seem like i'm being
defensive if it's well apparently it
goes sideways
and
it it doesn't matter so i'm not going to
talk about it well let me get in there
well let me just
insert let me insert myself into this
conversation
because i because uh
i i'll give my perspective of where i
was at in terms of the same thing okay
yeah which is yes and just like you were
i wasn't even yes ending any of the
wedding stuff i was just i was like
carte blanche you make all the decisions
that you want i don't this is not my
thing i mean i'm gonna be there and i'll
anything you want me to do anything you
need me to do i will do but i'm not
gonna come in and have an opinion about
colors of things and the only initiative
you took was shaving
buzzing your hair yeah for some reason a
few nights before but not my nether
regions i didn't trim that up i didn't
even think about that oh i did
because i i had a i had a friend who was
in the navy they don't have to shave
their cubes
he learned a lot in the name it's called
a crew cut man they all have to get it
no they don't have to shave their pubes
no but he said you should you should
really trim everything up down there
because
i mean he said in his words it's like
you look down and everything's more
impressive
i mean shadowed some people might need
that but
um so yeah i i i recall being i know
that i learned that information
before i got married so i think i put it
into practice because it stuck with me
i knew that jessie had never seen a
penis
i mean so she was going to be i i you
know all she had to compare it to was
she was never dug up any porn in the
forest she had never seen penis in
sexual context she had never worked i
think she'll talk about baseball she'll
talk about that a little bit later but
wow yeah but that was i i this is the
only thing that i first of all it was
kind of the only thing i was thinking
about for most of my life up until that
point and so it was we have been having
that now as that year turned into that
month turned into that week turned into
that day
i was just like the whole day the whole
wedding day i was like i'm going to have
sex at the end of this day i'm going to
get to have sex it feels surreal to meet
all these freaking people to think about
it so much talk to all these people and
smile at them yeah i mean to have them
good to have sex though to have this
wedding and the wedding was a big deal
there were hundreds and hundreds of
people at my wedding it was a it was a
huge endeavor
and i felt
like the night before i just fell ill
just i think was anxiety because i just
wanted
i i just felt everyone else's
expectations so i was very anxious about
the wedding and then
it my mind kept going to and then
there's this there's tonight
there's tonight
i'm so excited but now i'm i'm also
nervous and really keyed up and it's not
that christy and i hadn't talked about
it and we had been given books
and the books got more specific as the
time got closer and especially
for christy she remembers this that
there were a couple of
women
who she respected
in a spiritual sense like they were
involved in their churches and
they were
they had a practice of giving certain
books to
um
true love weights ladies who were about
to get married there was one book called
intended for pleasure which i think had
a spiritual context but it was
it was helpful and encouraging and it
was also like filling in all the
all the things you might have thought
you knew but you didn't know and how
things were going to work and
how to ease into it i remember christy
and i we were talking about
i guess there's a little bit of a pun
intended but talking about
like
not putting too much pressure on
ourselves but and also trying to foster
communication all along the way and just
easing into it
like
figuratively and i i guess literally as
well i mean that was something that was
kind of a concern it was like is this
gonna hurt i mean we had these
conversations because probably not for
you because somebody's
she was told that that it may be the
case for your first time it might hurt
she'll talk more about that but i just
remember
we were having these speculative
conversations
about this thing that was so built up in
our minds
and but we did have this runway of a
physical relationship in it so it wasn't
like
entirely flipping a switch another thing
that i'll wait for us to talk more about
with christy and jesse
but
we were in kinston for the wedding we
drove the hour and a half after the
wedding reception back to raleigh so we
could be close to the airport so like
you said the next day we could get on
the plane and we could go to jamaica man
mon
so we're going to jamaica so i you know
we i didn't want to like stay at her
parents house that night god forbid this
is the night
and i was concerned about how
well-rested we were going to be turns
out you get a a second wind whenever
it's you're ready to have sex for the
first time yeah yeah i mean it was like
we took our time
we each had things that we had decided
we were going to wear
we
we made a decision to not be in a hurry
and to enjoy each other
it was i don't recall it being really
awkward
again because
we had we had been physical in our
engagement and it had really started
ramping up like the
the
the intensity of desire
so
i mean
i think i think we were a little bit
nervous i think she was more nervous
than i was
but we just took it slow and then
it was successful
but and the eagle landed and i remember
as the eagles landing oh gosh i just
remember the the the predominant thought
in my mind
as the eagle was landing well what does
the eagle landing mean
um
it's actually happening we're actually
doing the old in and out okay we're
having sex okay thank you we're having
we're having intercourse okay good
understood okay do you understand so the
eagle is really landing landing but it
hasn't landed completely right as it as
it's actually happening it's like wow
this is happening
and then the the thought that i have was
this is free
this is free
i don't have to
pay as opposed to all the prostitutes
you have been with i don't understand i
never
i think i was such a frugal individual
who was so concerned about expenses
and budgeting you're such a weird man
that whenever i was like how can
something that is so amazing
it felt
so amazing and right you were saying i
am free like i know you're talking about
like i am free like i feel so free no
this this i am not paying for this this
is that
this is the best thing i've ever
experienced that's a man on a budget
right there and you know what
it doesn't cost a dime yeah that is
wonderful the most wonderful thing i've
ever experienced i'm currently
experiencing right now
and there was and it didn't cost
anything
interesting
now
you might say you didn't say it did you
i don't think i said it out loud i might
have said
free
but i was just like it was just like i
was just like going yay you were making
that or good god god bless you
the sensual dolphin sounds no i wasn't
making any of those noises
but yeah i remember that being my my
first reaction and um
i don't
i can't recall if there was more than
one session in the first night but i
once we got to jamaica
then it was like i just i definitely
remember there being
uh
saddle soreness
it was like at no cost i was like we
gotta slow our roll a little bit because
this is
this is
we're experiencing some soreness you
turned the faucet on much more her than
me the sink wasn't quite ready she was
she was experiencing some soreness okay
so for you it was free and that was and
it sounded like you had it you you had a
great time it was the contrast between
it being the best thing ever and you
typically for an experience that amazing
and all-encompassing
mind mind body and soul what i call the
mon
being engaged
but you you typically have to uh you
have to save up for something like that
you gotta and i one would could argue
that i did put it on layaway you've been
saying
there's a couple ways to take that
okay um so similar experience i guess
you didn't think that i definitely was
not thinking that it was free
uh but similar experience in that jessie
and i
were always even before we got married a
very communicative couple that
communicated
um
a lot of things to each other so
we were very comfortable with one
another and so again there wasn't an
awkwardness in terms of like oh you're
gonna see me you're gonna finally see me
naked no awkwardness from or to either
of the people in in the situation that
can be that there's there can be
especially in evangelicalism but just in
general in our culture there can be some
like shame around your body and that
kind of thing that wasn't a concern that
wasn't something that that we had to
deal with
and we had read the same books and we
had been to the same talks and we had
had you know certain like spiritual
mentors like kind of sit down and talk
to us so yeah i knew that my disposition
was going to want to move very quickly
more quickly quickly than she wanted to
and so going i'm going into it was like
i'm going to take it super slow come to
find out that i actually did not go that
slow
but in my mind compared to what i wanted
to do it felt like an eternity right
from her perspective which i think
she'll share it didn't feel the same way
okay um i was absolutely as i have made
clear
previously on this podcast obsessed with
uh what i'll now call the volvo
and so i knew that uh
more than just engaging in intercourse i
wanted to engage in i'll use the
i'll use the technical term connie
lingus but you will giggle
you will giggle the whole time i mean
it's a funny word it is a it's a good
word i don't even know if i can say it
um and so connie lingas so i was it
doesn't sound
like a technical word it sounds like an
urban dictionary term because it's like
it's got it's cunnie is part of it well
i think funny lingus would be an urban
dictionary
that's when you can't stop laughing when
you're doing it oh man that doesn't
happen to me that's cool though so
i knew that that was going to be one of
the key steps in the process because
i mean honestly to this day it still
kind of remains my favorite uh
thing on the sexual menu okay i'm just
gonna be honest with you and so i knew
that i wanted that to happen but we had
discussed that that was going to happen
so now that she would have been like oh
that's weird why are you going to do
that but um
it's the kind of thing you kind of want
somebody to know that's about to happen
right
and actually
we we discussed it beforehand and the
i mean
there was enough apprehension in like
how is this going to go
and let's
let's figure out how we want to step
through this process
and pace ourselves
if we had done so much planning and
pacing especially me and our dating
relationship that this was just this was
nothing new in conversations for us that
i was i we decided to err on the side of
you know what let's let's wait on oral
sex until we get
to
jamaica let's not put so much let's not
use those
let's not put like do the whole kitten
caboodle
in one night so we decided just to
stretch it out but know that like that
was something that we were going to
definitely get into very soon but not
the first night so that was awesome to
me there was a stream and we were on the
same page there was a strategy to it in
my mind it was like okay well i know
that there's a lot of concern about the
woman being ready
for right penetration yeah and so
i can get the thing that i've been
waiting for my entire life
and also accomplish the thing that these
people are telling me is really
important because i didn't know anything
about i looked at a lot of women's
bodies but i did not know anything
actually about a woman's body in sexual
anatomy the books that we read did tell
you how to know when a woman is ready
and not
so not to
get ahead of yourself or get ahead of
her that there's there's certain signs
of yeah when she's also ready so that
it's not
um traumatic or
you know more painful
than it needs to be or painful at all
and i will say again we we
we're speaking from what happened to us
and like link said
at the top like things turned out the
way they turned out for us because of
where we were at and what we believed at
a certain
particular time like going back and
saying like what if you could go back
would you do things differently it's
like well that's that question doesn't
even make sense because if i go back as
my current self
i'm going to make different decisions
but that in that in the place that i was
and the perspective that i had i also
agree that
waiting until that night because we were
both on the same page is what we both
wanted and it was the consistency with
our convictions and we were
communicating the whole time it made
that first night a very
a beautiful thing right it made it a
beautiful thing for me i'm not saying
that was because we waited it was
beautiful but it was a beautiful thing
and we had waited so you didn't pay for
it it was free yeah did you think about
it at the time
but so but i think and and we'll get the
the
you know the wives perspective on this
you know i we move i moved to the next
step in the process and of course we
were we were using condoms at the time
they weren't i think both of us because
that's right we were in that place where
we thought that birth control might
cause
an unintentional abortion or something
it's like we were in so deep at the time
guys so they weren't even on birth
control so we were just using condoms
um
and so that was an interesting i was
like i've never i've never even put one
on
do you know what i'm saying i think
maybe i put one on in practice like the
week before i was like i want to make
sure i can like get this thing on oh one
time when i i think i was 17 i went
i i went to the tmart in anger and they
had one of those machines in the
bathroom that sold condoms and other sex
toys uh for like four quarters they'll
give you a condom yeah and i so i was i
bought one there and put it on just to
see just to try it out i i just i was
curious so that's one thing that i did
before you i wore a condom you wouldn't
bought a condom just for the hell of it
yeah
i i just wanted to see what that was
like but i was like maybe this will help
with cleanup
well
not to dwell on it too much because
we've got other things to talk and then
i left the bathroom and got some fried
chicken but no i took it home but i will
say i think that it was beautiful
it was incredible from my perspective
we'll get jesse's perspective in a
moment
uh and then when we went to mexico that
week
something very interesting happened
which i we can unpack a little bit but
like i ended up having what i will refer
to as performance issues okay we had a
lot of sex
multiple times a day
but there were a couple of times where i
was just like i don't know really what's
going on here
there's this combination of finally
getting the thing that you've built up
in your entire life and it was
incredible and it was beautiful but i
there's so many things attached to it so
many things in my brain from the shame
that i had attached to it from the porn
that i had watched uh we may
answer a question about that about porn
and what our current view is on porn in
the in the last episode but
i think
there was just this sense of like being
completely overwhelmed with all these
things that were happening that i think
translated into
oh i am
here here we are in the middle of doing
this and i'm losing my erection
right and this which that could be scary
yeah well and then create a vicious
cycle and the interesting thing was is
that
you know here 20 years later as a
man in his mid-40s like this is not an
issue at all so it was not a physical
thing it was a psychological
thing sure just goes to show you how
much yeah the mental
component is at play
in in sex play and i think that there
was an element of
because that was happening and me not
understanding what was happening jesse
definitely not understanding what was
happening
that
we can we can get her perspective on
that in terms of did that make her feel
rejected like what how is she processing
that now i want to be clear that it
wasn't a persistent problem not because
i'm ashamed of it just to be to be clear
and it was something that kind of moved
through relatively quickly but
and it was i kind of isolated mostly to
that that week and then that first year
of marriage and then slowly kind of just
went away and i think it just had to do
with the fact that this thing that i had
to crystallize in my mind as a certain
thing
then was happening on a regular basis
and then i started realizing
oh this isn't
this is everything that i thought it
would be in terms of the physicality but
there's this other component to
making love
that
is almost a service in a sense right
there's a there's a service aspect to to
caring about the other person yeah that
can sometimes make sex seem like oh man
i just kind of want to just have sex i
don't really want to make love right now
do you know what i'm saying yeah and i
think that that dynamic is something
that i did not anticipate
being
a sticking point
uh in our marriage but let's let's uh
let's take a short break and then we're
not virgins anymore and then on the
internet and then get the
get the wives on the line yeah go to
mythical.com uh for all
your sexual fantasy needs i mean just
for your
not actually none of that
uh i can recommend other sites for that
we got a backpack oh crap here it is
right here oh you've had it on the whole
time or just had it behind it's been on
my seat
check out this mythical backpack
it's padded it's got a laptop slot it's
got mythical written all over it
including a mythical
rubber
logo right here which is nice
it's got an outer pocket and it's got
some really
comfort
first straps mythical.com put all your
condoms in there
i'm just trying to tie it in yeah we
don't sound like mythical condoms you
don't want a mythical condom you want a
real one that works
your boys on your backpack mythical.com
[Music]
okay so we've got
our wives here with us hello ladies
jesse thank you for doing this how how
do you feel about doing this christy
i have diarrhea
okay all right well okay
that's not what we're talking about
today
hey you know it's uh if you if you want
it
this is a confessional podcast and
that's a great start does that does that
and that's really sexy i gotta say that
how is that related i think jessie i
think jesse does too right jessie i woke
up with diarrhea as well thank you oh my
gosh
so you guys are you guys are nervous you
guys are feeling it feeling it feeling
the nerves and talking about this stuff
well i mean you're totally easing us in
to coming on the podcast right like the
first time we come on the podcast all we
have to do is talk about our sex lives
yeah yeah no big deal easy no no biggie
we wanted to rip the band-aid off
well and here's my thing i'm one of the
most private people ever
and
somehow y'all have talked me into coming
on this podcast to talk about my most
intimate relationship with the internet
and
i don't i don't know how i feel about it
how did that other than diarrhea
but i i mean how did that happen because
you did decide i'm not coercing you to
do this that because if anybody's going
to talk about having sex with you it has
to be me
bingo
jesse what about you how did you how did
you get comfortable enough to say yes to
doing this
um i mean the same
it feels you know there's
there's definitely been
talk about christy
and i on the podcast and we've often
talked about how
we do have our own story um you know not
just with deconstruction but with so
many of these things
um and if
you know it's been a conversation for a
long time went about when we would be
ready to come on if we wanted to come on
what we wanted to share
but i think
knowing that y'all were going to be
talking about sex
it feels like
we can't in some ways not share
um
not that we were coerced you have our
full consent to be here but
yeah you guys are i'm not gonna do
rhett's song i'm not um
it's horrible anyway brave or talented i
haven't done it the first time
um but you know
christy and i are both the only people
that you guys have individually
had sex with and
we are
i'm glad you said individually thank you
we are
um
also you know i am excited to get to
share some of the woman's perspective
that's something that is is you know is
missing um just because of the nature of
what your podcast is well that's that's
i mean that's exactly why we wanted you
to be a part of it again it wasn't
necessarily well thought out because we
would we told you a little bit you know
not completely last minute but after we
had made the decision to do sex symbol
we were like ah like we're talking all
about
our sex lives in our sex lives
as they exist now and have for quite
some time
we kind of only exist with you yeah
we put you between a rock and a hard
place uh which might be a euphemism for
our honeymoon night yeah uh so let's get
into that yeah because thanks for
thanks for being willing to do this and
i know that it's it it it makes such an
impact in people's lives to hear
again destigmatizing these type of
conversations and it not just being our
perspectives but yours as well means a
lot to us so and we just so we just
shared what our
sort of perspective on
finally getting to have sex was like as
you can imagine what uh what we shared
you were there um
but we'd like to hear from y'all like
growing up and kind of being raised in
purity culture being such a part of it
you know we were
all about to go on staff a crusade like
we were in it right and then to and
all of us having waited until that first
night like what was it like to finally
be able to
break you know whatever have sex
essentially and christy why don't you
take this one first
oh thank you yeah
what do you remember
about that night or or the build up to
it
well
i mean i was
i was definitely a lady in waiting
um
which means that that was a book i don't
remember who wrote it but that was a
book that
our bible study
did that was basically right beside my
bible and everything
the checklist of the proverbs 31 woman
um
was something that i looked at a lot and
i tried to be her
and
uh
i i couldn't i couldn't be her
um but i was i appreciated it was a high
standard
yeah it was very specific
a little bit and it was all in
relationship to the husband and the
family as far as i can remember
you know everything was contextualized
and
yeah like um at
first like there were
there were a lot of rules um around
me as a woman
i somehow believe that um
you know that god didn't want me to
wear spaghetti straps or
gods didn't want me to wear a two-piece
bathing suit anymore
or
um
you know i i had to protect you
from my body
um so i had to cover my body
and
i didn't want to cause you
to you know use some evangelical
christian words to stumble or
to sin like that was that was my
responsibility because you were the
spiritual leader and i had to protect
you
from myself
um you know so that was
i liked the rules because it felt safe
and as an enneagram six i really value
security and safety
um
so there was there was a part of that
that i was kind of comfortable with um
and
i
you know you were like the first super
christian that i ever dated
so
you know like super devout yeah
super devout like
you you didn't want to hold my hand
except for like in certain like at
certain points or like maybe on on a on
a random wednesday you would call me and
want to hold my hand and for some like
for some reason i thought that was okay
and that was great
because i contextualized it in
spirituality which is what i
which what i was taught so i think that
you knew that my heart behind it i was
in the right place and you were like but
it was weird
well it was kind of weird because i was
like what is he attracted to me of
course i of course i know he's attracted
to me but he's just being really
disciplined and
really strong
um
and
we're gonna be rewarded for this on our
honeymoon night and if we would have
stayed that chaste like as chased as we
were up until our engagement that we
didn't kiss or
rarely hold hands or have a physical
relationship
i can only i mean i feel like our
wedding night would have been it would
have been it could have gone anyway
it could have gone a lot of ways it
didn't go right
so well i mean how do you feel if you
fast forward to that night
how do you how did you feel going into
it what do you remember
well
i remember like i had two
i had two ladies
like the week before kind of sit down
and talk to me about the wedding night
um
and so i kind of knew what was gonna
happen i wasn't really sure but like
i was just gonna go with it but it it
was really weird like i was excited but
it was also just really really awkward
because it was like some switch like you
hear sometimes people like turn on turn
them turn it off and on and switch right
from
nothing
like we can't do anything and all of a
sudden we can do everything
um
so that was just kind of
that was just kind of hard for me we had
a ramp up i mean our physical
relationship really got going once we
got engaged and so then there was like
that i mean you kind of you know well i
mean i've i've spoken about the the gene
jamming
thanks for speaking about that and not
telling me that you're speaking about
that
i just did tell you that i did speak
about it i mean
so we had i mean
there was no doubt that like the sparks
were flying and that we were doing
everything we could to not have
intercourse until that night so it
wasn't i mean there was
and we had talked about how we were
going to approach it right that we were
going to ease into pray like we prayed
what we prayed yes we did didn't we you
forgot oh yes we played so we get you
you're supposed to pray
well honey wedding night on the wedding
night it was a wedding night
okay we weren't supposed to pray
together before because it was too
intimate that was the thing y'all were
looking forward to is praying together
we did didn't we like we got to the room
let me tell you what we did
we
we knelt down
beside the bed and held hands and we
prayed together you don't remember this
completely naked
no i still had all my beautiful satin
thingy that my mama bought me
you we had you had on your lingerie and
we got down on our knees and prayed
yes
babe we did
that is awesome
i love that you don't remember that
i i remember it now but i i'd forgotten
that we did that and then what
the satin thingy came off
[Laughter]
it didn't come off enough and that
that's enough to share about that had
you seen
a wiener
had you seen a winner
i think it's time for jesse to take over
now
okay jesse had you seen a wiener
i know the answer to this because
rhett's already said
i was actually going to talk about
whether or not i had seen a wiener i'm
sorry
read already we're winning it link
do you want me to start with how to do
it no just start with i'm going to start
start with where you want to start with
answering the question
thank you
jesse it's just our vibe and our energy
is so connected i knew you wanted to
talk about it thank you christy
i love you yeah go for it um okay so
i had definitely
um gotten all the memos about sex being
sex outside of marriage being bad
um not something you wanted to do a lot
of the same
as chris you know at my
my body
could make men stumble what i wore
could make men stumble i mean i remember
being at this christian camp and having
like
uh crying come to jesus moment over
my two-piece bathing suit
and like
promising god that i would never wear a
two-piece bathing suit again of course i
wore a two-piece bathing suit again but
like there was a lot of
internal turmoil over my two-piece
bathing suit a lot of pressure
um
you know
not only
was sex bad sexually adjacent things
that could get you going
were
not ideal and i think rhett talked about
his standard was higher even than my
standard was
um in the beginning
um and that that changed
um but i think along with that idea
you know i'm christy said she's an
enneagram six i'm an enneagram two
and my like instinctual
subtype is one to one or
the sexual subtype
and so like that what that means is that
like
i am oriented to the world around my
close relationships and like i
wanna be close i want to be
super connected like i'm a naturally
very like touchy feely affectionate
person
and so i feel like i had been
holding so much of that back for all
these years
and so i had this idea that like
once i got married you know if sex
outside of marriage was bad well sex
inside of marriage was not only good it
was like
life-changing earth shattering
world building like which is
true right
it was you know it was going to be this
otherworldly like not just physical
union but spiritual union the bible said
so to become one flesh it's like you
cannot this was
a
code
you know i struggle with codependency so
this was like a biblically mandated like
dream for a codependent person like i
can actually totally merge with this
person that
i'm in love with um
so was it so was it good and and
i had never seen an
adult penis
i mean
okay meaning you had seen like a baby
penis
you saw the nirvana everybody's seen
baby penises
[Applause]
so like i you know mine is adult just
just so you know i mean i was only 22 or
23 but it was adult
full grown
um
you know and an older woman had told me
in trying to prepare me
that um
that
the male genitalia looked like
a man's insides had grown up
on the outside
well like a hernia it's not an
inaccurate description
and you were so ready to be connected to
that oh gosh
wow so i mean
i with all of that like background all
this like pressure all of i'm also an
idealist so i had like
you know
sex was gonna be like
the greatest thing
and if you kiss the frog it'll turn into
a prince
i would say you know it was
anticlimactic
not to be too on the nose
well
you mean you literally did not climax
yes i did not i've never had an orgasm
before i didn't know my body i really
know how to have an orgasm
and also
like i mean this had nothing to do with
rhett or me it just was like
huh
okay
that was a lot of build up for
something that
was
like fine
but it's okay because we're going to get
to try again anytime we want
and it's free
great that's what link said hold on
christie you don't remember my
my the thing that was going through my
mind the first time we had sex i don't
know that was it
this is amazing and it's free
okay
you know i was i was just very
frustrated he's a strange man we all
know that we've been i don't i don't
yeah i don't know what to say about that
so okay so we heard what was going
through jesse's mind i didn't i don't
want to cut you off is there more that
was going through your mind jesse
because i want to hear what was going
through christie's mind in the act as
well
because you were like okay that's
that was it huh i mean i just think the
the whole thing
especially the first time you know i
just
it was
it was
fine
it was just kind of it's pretty good for
me
i was having the time of my life
yeah you know
probably sooner than i expected it to be
i mean hey listen i admit that
i admit that
um yeah
of course
christy what about you what what do you
remember thinking as it was
happening
i i really don't remember
thinking a whole lot like just like the
mechanics of like how like how is this
gonna how do we do this um
um
i like we had three mechanics in the
room yeah right they had wrenches very
sexy
yeah but it was like yeah it was
everything you think of any aspect of it
you're like well i can imagine but i
remember there was some trepidation
because it was like is this gonna hurt
yeah i mean like that part
i don't remember it really hurting just
feeling like awkward
um
and then okay but this is supposed to
feel good so like this is just something
that we're gonna have to work on like
and we do like we get we get to do this
whenever we want to as many times a day
as we want to try and like
we will get better at this and
this
is what i've been waiting for
but there were no you don't recall any
sparks flying or any like
what kind of
i mean are you trying to get me to say
something
no i i i'm just saying that was my
experience and that there's a contrast
there which is interesting well like i
was excited about um i got my mom my
mama let me go to the tanning bed
um yeah
yeah before i got married and that was
like the only time that she let me go to
the tanning bed so like i don't know if
y'all remember but like they had these
little playboy bunny stickers stickers
yeah and so i had really been working on
my sticker placement and my and my tan
and like i was excited to show you by
tan
oh i was excited to see it i remember
there being like
less tanned hearts
i don't remember a playboy bunny i think
i put hearts in certain places and
playboy bunnies and i was i was excited
about being that tan and like
you getting to see me super tan well all
you know what you're probably the only
one who didn't me and jesse both went to
the tanning bed before our wedding did
you not go i'm sure i was tanned but i
needed no bed well but to get how you
gonna get your cheeks tan
you can't you could you wanna go out on
the pool side somewhere yeah expose
yourself
this is lake we're talking about well i
didn't wanna have burnt buns tan in bed
um that's right jesse right that is not
free
it is not free so
i think there's a common theme here in
that um
you know frankly you know neither of you
had an orgasm on your wedding night
neither of you kind of understood
necessarily what that
was and what that would feel like it was
something that thankfully we eventually
uh
came to figure out
um and i will say i do want to give
credit to like
the
men in
like campus crusade who had talked to at
least rhett i'm assuming link too and we
were talking a little bit about this
last night like that book intended for
pleasure which i don't think i read but
y'all did read there was even though you
know we were dealing with purity culture
and all the ways that
messed us up and and
uh
you know there is so much hurt and pain
because of that however
there was a lot of like discussion about
the woman's pleasure
as well
um in marriage of course it had to be
within the context of marriage but that
was something that was talked about
with with
at least
rhett was was talked with yeah yeah
definitely me too but you guys were
never encouraged i mean i know because
we weren't either to masturbate in order
to understand yourself
and so it's like there was this
dependence on
absolutely being within marriage and
waiting to have to figure all that out
yeah so first of all first of all you
did not give us anything on our three
questions that we thought we might be
talking about and there wasn't anything
about orgasm or masturbating on it so i
think you're trying to trick us into
talking about this and i don't
appreciate it
okay but yeah i could i but that was
really really kind of a joke right was
that kind of a joke i'm very happy to be
here though
i'm very happy to be here
well she is smiling when she's saying
these things
go ahead i think like something that i
kind of wanted to say and like
um
you know there was
like jesse was saying
there is a lot from purity culture that
has been
kind of you know traumatizing and
scarring and just really hard that we've
worked through
um you know as adults
and
you know for me
i
i didn't realize you know like i i kind
of liked the rules there were a lot of
things that i feel like i feel grateful
for um
our dating relationship
and just how it was led and
you know yeah there were frustrating
things but i also felt safe um now was
that an illusion of safety maybe i don't
know but
um i felt safe and i didn't really
realize um
that
like a lot of the trauma or the shame
um
until like i would say just in like you
know the last 10 or 15 years
as i've like been going through my
deconstruction
of oh this is wait a minute this is
actually part of
purity culture
and um you know so just now are you
thinking of a specific example well i
mean just like as a 43 year old woman
like
learning to
you know love
love my body and
that it is okay to wear a tank top and
like you know like i'm 43 and i still
will
think about
oh well that i mean i can't i can't wear
oh yes i can like it just it's very
ingrained
um you know and like we have an 18 year
old daughter and like
i want her to be able to express herself
and wear what she wants to wear and like
you know jesse and i talk about this a
lot like we don't want our own
stuff or our own
trauma to be projected on what we
tell our kids and like what we
what we say to our kids and it's like oh
i want lily to be free in all the ways
that i wasn't and wear what she wants to
yeah i i do think we're finding this
we're hoping to find this middle ground
where there's
purity culture has its damaging elements
but it's it's designed to
it
it creates fear
and shame but it's to protect you from
things that like i don't know i don't if
we'd have gone to the other extreme
right we only know what we've been
through right we don't know what what
could have befallen us there
so obviously but we were on an extreme
right and so there's some negatives to
it so i think it's looking for that
middle ground where we're not projecting
on our kids but we are trying to inform
and protect them and i i mean i think
that's getting into the next question is
parenting but i do want to clarify too
because i i i want to be clear that i'm
when you say middle ground i don't think
what you're saying is that you're trying
to arrive at a middle ground in your
perspective on purity culture because i
think that would come across as
insensitive correct and also i don't
think that's what you mean and we'll
talk about this as we get into talking
about parenting
what i would say is that
we navigated a system that was set up to
to get you to a place where you got to
marriage without having sex and if you
could navigate it
it could work and and it worked for both
of you and a lot of things fell into the
right places right it would work and you
could be safe and you could be happy
but just statistically speaking it's
just a fact that in places that teach
the abstinence-only education and that
purity culture is sort of
what the is with the cultural norm for
teens like those there's just there's a
lot more damage and destruction left in
the wake of that mentality than there is
situations like us like i almost there's
a part of me that almost feels like i i
don't i feel like we almost are
misrepresenting things because we're two
really good cases of how this could turn
out but when you look at statistics you
know teen pregnancy and stds in
mississippi are a lot higher than they
are in washington state you know what
i'm saying and there's a lot more
christians and a lot more purity culture
in mississippi than there is in
washington state what i'm saying is
there's got to be another way i agree
what you're saying and how you clarify
what i'm saying there's got to be
another way to to protect our kids and
educate our kids and give them
standards for their own integrity yeah
that they can then begin to live by
right so i think the question and jesse
we'll have you take this one first is
as parents
um
how has the fact that our world view has
shifted dramatically that we're no we no
longer consider ourselves christians or
to have a christian ethic when it comes
to sex
but we've got kids
and we gotta we gotta tell them
something about sex right so how has our
approach to parenting how is your
approach to parenting and the way that
you you talk about sex and think about
sex in terms of
parenting how has that changed as your
world view has changed
well i think i mean i want to start out
by saying
parenting is the hardest thing i've ever
done
and that's not a reflection on my kids
that's
just
like
it's just the reality of it like trying
to figure out
you know and maybe a bit a large part of
that is like
is a change in perspective is knowing
that you know coming to the conclusion
that the way that i
did it you know our dating story my
beliefs
they were a way they were not the way
um and so
you know i think
it it does make you feel
um
kind of
in some ways
anchorless um
and like okay what i had this framework
i had this very black and white this
very binary way of of seeing the world
of teaching my children of and like
sure it was you know as christy said
sure there were rules but it also was
like very clear
um and now
i am things are not clear
things are not black and white
um
which is one of the reasons you know
i've been in a lot of therapy
and
i would never
deign to give somebody parenting advice
because i think
parenting again it's the hardest thing
i've ever done it is
every kid is different every parent is
different every back story is different
every town is different every you know i
i just
to try to say this one way is the best
and this is gonna work for everybody and
then there's the question of well what
does work mean
you know what is what do you even mean
by that i mean you look you say like
okay our relationships worked well
we're still together i think you know i
would say both of us have really healthy
loving as far as
as i know
like we both feel
happily committed to each other
um but that may not be somebody else's
definition of working it i have kind of
taken on like a
harm reduction
um model
in parenting
and it's like i know i'm gonna do harm
because i'm a human they're humans
how can i do the least amount of harm
how can they
which maybe sounds fatalistic
but you know i just i
i think the best thing i can do as a
parent is to work on my own [ __ ]
so that i don't project it onto my kids
so that i don't
believe that their journey
has to look like mine
so that i don't
try to have them fulfill unfulfilled
dreams or meet some standard that i
didn't meet or a standard that i did
meet
um
yeah
i don't know well you know one of the
things that we've been talking about uh
it me and you i know um
is that
man it would be easy
not easy it would be easier and this may
just be my perspective because i'm no
longer in it it would be easier if i
could just give the kids the blueprint
and the framework i'm like this is what
you're supposed to do this is what
you're not supposed to do here it is
it's in this book it's not really in
this book but we've kind of added on and
made it seem like it's in this book and
here it is
take it and now i just i've given you
all the information and do with it what
you will
it that from a parent standpoint
that sort of one size fits all these are
the rules for everybody is a much easier
thing to do once you start saying
actually
maybe it's different for different
people
and not everybody's the same and
everybody's on a different point of the
spectrum now it gets cloudy and it gets
complicated
you know one of the things that
i've said you call call it the harm
reduction model
the way that i've kind of worked it out
in my brain is that as opposed to
approaching
you know the way i think about sex and
the way i think about parenting when it
comes to sex and from a moral framework
i think about it from a health
framework right like what's actually the
healthiest thing because i know for a
fact that our kids whether i
in some some regards i think whether we
had told them this or not whether we had
given them a christian framework or not
i don't necessarily think they would be
abiding by it
but the fact is is that they don't have
the same ideological framework that we
had coming up that kept us so in lock
step with each other and committed to
these principles and so to put those
expectations on them to behave in the
same way that we did would be a
ludicrous expectation that would do so
much damage to our relationship
but like link said but there are
realities about the nature of sex right
there's consequences to sex like sex is
you know very pleasurable but sex is
also the primary means by which we
procreate so pregnancy that's an option
stis that that can happen
emotional entanglement is something that
can happen there's there's a lot of
different things that are just realities
about sexual relationships right so i
think the the model that go ahead
well no i mean i was just gonna say you
know i think
one
one other element that you know
in thinking about those things of course
open communication trying to work on my
own shame about sex so that i don't
project that shame onto my kids and they
have shame um you know having a other
adults in their life that they can talk
to whether that's a therapist or like a
younger an aunt or an uncle or whoever
that like you know they're not going to
want to tell me everything
um
sometimes they'll tell me more than i
want to know
but just having you know i think
one thing that we miss out a lot in in
the way that we live now is that we
don't have the community
aspect that we have at other times where
you have these other people that you
trust that your kids trust that they can
you know talk about these things too and
like one other thing i want to say i
just want to clarify like in saying i
felt anchorless
um you know i think that has negative
connotations for sure
and yet
the more
stuff the more of my own stuff i work
out
the more i feel it as like a freedom
and an openness like one thing i've said
to red is like i feel like
i'm kind of in an open field in my mind
in a way that like i hadn't been in the
past
um
and so
and the more in
in parenting one thing we talk a lot
about in therapy with my parenting is
like the tighter i grip on to an idea or
a standard or whatever it is usually the
worse things go
and
the more i
release
and the more i trust and the more i i'm
not talking about being naive i'm not
talking about letting your kids do
whatever they want i'm just talking
about like a a
um
kind of positioned towards my children
of like they are their own beautiful
souls
um
whose
life and journey and
destiny all of it is going to look
different than mine and like what can i
do to
help them
become
to help them know that they are gonna
mess up they are gonna not um
not
always live up to their own standards
whatever those may be
um
you know in the same way the more that i
model that in my own life i think the
more that frees them up to be able to do
that as well
christy where's your head at when it
comes to
this conversation let's let's get in on
it
i mean i
i agree with a lot of the things that um
jesse has shared and yeah
i mean i
i think
like
love and acceptance
and communication
um
you know have just been
like i mean my therapist we were just
talking about it yesterday she was just
like
your family
y'all talk
so much to each other
and like
um
yet
they're still
humans individual humans
on their own path
run in their own race
that have their own opinions and will
make their own decisions
and
i am not
very good at opening my hands and just
watching it happen
um
because you know it's there there is so
much of it that's beautiful um
when you do see
this this human like grow up into like
this adult and like
it's
it's kind of cool like to see
the woman that lily has become and like
um
watching lincoln become a man and like
just kind of watching them figure out
life
um
you know because they don't of course
they don't want to talk to their parents
about sex
but i just want it to be something that
we can talk about openly like why does
it have to be so weird to talk about sex
like
i think that's my fault
i think i'm the reason well we can just
make everything everything
i was gonna say we can just say that
really about everything because you make
everything awkward
um right so it kind of brings everything
up to a weirdness that is usually
reserved for just sex talk i bring
everything to sex talk weird so then sex
talk weird this is camouflaged i mean
when we first but yeah it's
destigmatizing the word sex like in the
house in my house growing up and in my
family
you just didn't use the word or you
whispered it
and like on the way i was dropping land
off lando off at school this morning he
was like
i was talking about getting the
technical stuff set up for you to join
she was like he was like what is she
what is mom doing it's like oh we're
doing you know where we're having the
series about sex and he's like oh
you don't have to talk to me about that
i'm like but
we do want there's nothing wrong with
talking about sex and we want to talk
about it openly because it's not
something that needs to be whispered
about so i'm telling him that at that
moment that's like the instinct to be
to to to flee from the word and the
concepts at
as an 11 year old
is something that hey we just want to
gently push back on and not
and not whisper about well i think and
make that one decision the fundamental
differences that i see between the way
that we thought about sex you know 20
years ago and the way we think about it
now
is that
i was in a place as a conservative
evangelical where
i had been sort of misled and lied to
like things were mischaracterized but
all in the name of protecting you right
so it's like we're going to lie or we're
going to come up with things that are
not true about the way condoms work and
the way aids the hiv can get through the
condom and christie can speak to that i
mean christie what did you what's one of
the things that you heard that kept you
from having sex in high school
well um that my
my favorite grandmother that was already
in heaven was watching me
the cloud of witnesses
yeah and is she was she in the center
well i don't i mean
did that stop she got married well
that's she's like that's what i'm gonna
say it's like i mean i guess she's still
watching me she's clapping
oh she's clapping oh christy she's happy
but
the idea that we had to be told things
that weren't true to protect us from
something and it was rigid it was one
size fits all i think the biggest
difference for me at this point is like
the more truth that i can dispense into
this situation the more things i can say
the more my kid can know about this the
more because listen like i said there's
it's not saying that like oh sex is free
sex is free
and have it have it with anybody anytime
you want there are no consequences it's
been completely it's not a sacred thing
it's just a physical act i don't believe
that i think it's a beautiful thing i
think it's a sacred thing i think there
are big deep consequences to it i think
it's something that should be taken
seriously but i think i don't have to
make that up i think that's just that's
an evidence-based approach based on the
consequences of this act and the the
nature of the way humans are emotionally
so
it's more of a it's it's more trusting
listen this is difficult difficult to do
trusting your children right and saying
i'm going to give you all the
information i'm going to do my best to
model the things that i think that you
should do because i know my modeling is
going to be much more effective than my
talking to you
um and then hoping for the best versus
just trying to protect them and give
them some some rigid rules that i know
they're not gonna follow does that make
sense well and i mean i think that we
all want a formula for parenting i know
i do i would love
to have a formula that you do this this
and this and it spits out
this kind of kid who then is going to
fulfill all of my dreams about
how i was gonna parent and how
a kid was gonna be or do or whatever
and that just
it doesn't exist it wouldn't be good for
us if it did exist
you know i think the most
the most growth
i've had to see in my own life has been
through like struggling through some of
these parenting questions and continuing
continuing to struggle through them yeah
i think um
and coming out of our experience and now
ushering our kids through their own
experiences that are so different than
ours we can't it's hard we cannot speak
from our experience as much yeah so we
have
we're learning so much at the same time
and just tr i i think trying to foster
a trust with our kids where we can have
difficult conversations
and where we're not
the
the end-all be-all bringing the the
authority to every point of view
in every issue but we're tr but there's
things that we're having to figure out
together yeah and it is particularly
challenging
uh yeah and i i was gonna say like you
know between me and jesse and then like
our girlfriend thread like
we
like i'm keeping this list of
things that they didn't tell you at a
baby shower yeah yeah and you know
because when when you're pregnant you
know you decide to have kids and you
become pregnant and then you go to this
baby shower and
let's talk about the stroller and the
car seat and the diapers and all these
things that that
you know you you're bringing in a
newborn and a human and it's just like
when do we get to talk about like
raising teenagers and like sex well
right when you're in the middle of it
and you're screwing it all up and you
don't know what you're doing
yeah
yeah but i mean that yeah but the other
i mean but the on the other foot what do
you say on the other hand on the other
foot either one
um
[Laughter]
you also but that like that book doesn't
that it doesn't exist it's like what
jesse's saying it's like that formula
isn't there like
because each kid is different and each
parent is different and like you just
have to figure it out yeah and we want
to go ahead and move on to the last
question just because i know people want
to hear us talk about maintaining a
vibrant sexual relationship
after
21 years of marriage 21 years of sex
so
christy let us have it
um
well let's see
um
i
uh
i don't know what i want to say right
now
hold on
i i okay go ahead can can you start yeah
i i mean one of the things that i i
think before we got married and it's a
thought that comes up a lot for me is
that
sex is
not a
thermostat it's a thermometer
and i think that still rings true
is that it's
you can't have sex in order to make
to manipulate your relationship into a
better place
but your sex life
more often than not can be a good
indicator of how well your relationship
how how well you feel connected
in in the other areas of your
relationship i don't i want to reserve
the right to say that's not a blanket
statement and that they there is an
interplay both ways
but
um
you know there's i guess it at the risk
of it being the sexist remark to say
that sex begins in the kitchen i don't i
don't know if i like that specifically
but the general principle of
our physical intimacy
is first of all insects is paired with
an emotional
intimacy that then is fueled by our
relationship in all other areas
and so if things if we're going through
a difficult time
with each other it's like you know that
that makes sex more difficult or
if we're going through a difficult time
together about other things
it makes sex more difficult but um
and over the course of 20 years
we've we've weathered so many things
that have built
uh
and strengthened our love for each other
we've lived multiple lives together
and
miraculously remained together
um and i think that is reflected in our
sex life that it's a it's a priority for
us and right but but that
that means that sometimes
it needs to be scheduled so that we will
follow through with it so these are some
of the things i'm thinking you pick up
on any of that you want okay i got you i
got you um yeah i i think like
priority is the word that i needed to
hear to get me started thank you for
that
little
verbal foreplay there
[Laughter]
i think like
i do believe that our sexual
relationship is um
sacred
and that's why i don't
i don't know it's just like to
take care of it just like i would any
other aspect of our relationship
and um
i think
the two of us
separately learning
as much about
like being on our own journey and
learning what we have about ourselves
individually um
has
made it aware like we're like closer now
than we've ever been and
um
dealing
like we dealt a lot with like i think
about the in sickness and health like
we've we've dealt a lot with like my
sicknesses and
being on different medications that like
take my sex drive away and like oh well
we can't be on that medication because
this is really important to us so let's
switch medications and
um
you know just really taking time to
i understand and appreciate what you
need you understand and appreciate what
i need like we take a lot of trips
together because
i have anxiety and i need to get out of
my house
in order to really
focus and like i feel like some of our
best
sex is when we're on trips oh oh yeah
you know it's like you take me we take
each other to like these beautiful
places and like
i am really able to be present and
um
because at home you've got like
is there a kid that's going to try to
come through the door and our lock
doesn't quite work because if it fully
works then we're locked in well
but now it's like saka and jasper like
saka and jasper it's not even the kids
anymore it's the animals but but i made
a i made a point i was like listen
dogs pets are not going to ever be a
reason that we're not going to have sex
barbara we had this conversation goes
into her crate she's just like
instinctual they kind of know she like
looks kind of shameful and just kind of
just goes into a crate
and daddy are doing that thing again and
and you know what if if it it's a big
enough bed if the dog's gonna stay on
the bed the dog's gonna stay on the
other side of the bed but the dog is not
i don't like that like it is an
unacceptable reason like this is
something that we agreed on right it's
like yeah yeah totally because you can
find yourself having there's so many
circumstances that keep you from not not
being ready or it not being the right
time the proverbial headache of it all
but it's so much more than that when
you've got
so much life that you're living
that you have to say and you get
exhausted so it's like
at 9 30 one of us is asleep nine o'clock
maybe one of us is asleep so it's like
okay gotta get started let's do day sex
but then when are the kids not gonna be
around
i mean i also think that like
creativity in like
locations and like being willing to
wait i mean you could have sex in other
places than like your bed and i'm not
talking about like going on trips but
i'm talking about
get creative the stairs
one time we locked ourselves in the
garage
because
the garage locked in such a way that
like no one could get in there that was
fun because we had a mattress in there
that we were storing
oh yeah the old one it wasn't that old
it was covered jesse
jesse give us your perspective on this
i mean
i
i want to say that like i do feel like
you know our
sex life is better than it's ever been
and it's something that
continues to like continues to get
better and better and
you know i learned
something
about you a few weeks ago
that
i had a second penis that um
just let her talk that i decided to
finally review i actually want to know
what
you she learned if she's willing to
share i'm not gonna no i'm not gonna
tell you what i learned oh come on
people can benefit
the i think you know in the same way
that like you can get into negative
communication patterns in your marriage
like it's very easy to get into patterns
like with how you have sex or how you or
this person's going to do this then i'm
going to do this and whatever and so
continuing to like
talk to talk about things continuing to
um
ask hard questions continuing to be like
vulnerable i mean that's the thing i
think
i
sometimes i think i have more of a
problem of like over sharing just in
general
but i think in our marriage to be able
like to continue i mean having growing
sexually with your partner is a constant
um kind of willingness to be vulnerable
and to maybe be embarrassed um but to
know that like
it's worth it
um
to try new things to try new places to
try new whatever you know one of my
favorite
favorite people who talks about sex is
astaire perel she has a great
podcast can i
wreck another podcast on your podcast is
that yeah is that a bad thing to do yeah
it's better than this one
but you know where should we begin um is
her podcast where she talks to
couples um about what's going on in
their life
what's going on in the relationship and
often you know their sex is involved and
she
has done a lot of research and on human
sexuality eroticism and so one of the
things she says is
love enjoys knowing everything about you
and desire needs mystery
um and so i think you know it's hard to
do when you have been married for 20
years so
continuing to find new ways to to have
mystery you know rhett's really great at
accents
would you like to see my second wee-wee
ah cookie monster loving cookie
how about that yeah
nibble nibble cookie cookie yeah you
don't know the half of it you know i
think not like
knowing that it's important not often it
takes one person one partner being
willing to like
put something out there
you're maybe gonna be embarrassed about
it but it's gonna be worth it
um
and you know we have so much
fear and shame
around sex and like
there's so much
potential
for it to be
incredible and i think the more
vulnerable and open and
real and creative
you can be
um
the better it is but there ain't nothing
wrong with a quickie every now and again
just to like absolutely
i mean as long as you're using the
cookie monster accent
but i mean even that you know that's
something we talk about like okay what's
our ratio of quickies to like love
making
what what is like the good the golden
ratio
of that
um
and
again it's just like
the combination of like being willing to
be open and vulnerable but then also
figuring out the ways to discover your
partner anew and to find mystery
well
we could continue talking to y'all for
hours
um
but we actually can't right and i know
people would want that but um
so listen thank you for coming on here
and
being vulnerable like you said this is
the the
the first time you've been on the pike
the podcast and you're talking about
these jumping in the deep end this is
the best way yeah this is the best way
just rip the band-aid off get right into
it i know that a lot of people out there
will appreciate
your perspective and so i'm glad you're
able to give a little bit of the other
side of the coin
it's a needed perspective and you're in
in very needed in uh just our lives we
need you yeah each individually
the labia to our
[ __ ] and balls oh lord
okay
well
thank you for having us this is just
wonderful
it was really beautiful
uh love you baby you're gonna go uh
what what's the word when you
talk about what just happened debrief
thank you that's the one yeah
i'm gonna change my shirt because of my
armpits wet
all right all right started out with
diarrhea ended with armpit sweat we'll
see
see you tonight keep it real
all right
[Music]
okay so the girls have gone back to
whatever they need to be doing today and
we are left in basking in the afterglow
of having them on ear biscuits talking
about that was wonderful it was
thrilling and i know that everyone is
just going to
wish that they were on every single week
or maybe in place of us maybe i feel a
little threatened um
you know and i think they did so well i
think um i mean obviously each one of
those the the thing is that each one of
those questions could have been
its own episode and also i mean each one
of those questions could be its own
podcast with multiple episodes yeah like
exploring one of those things and i'm
sure those exist but so we you know i
think that we kind of scratched the
surface on a few of those things but i
do think that getting their perspective
uh
illuminated these issues in a big way i
we did want to just take before we wrap
up link's going to kick off the story
which i think it ties in perfectly with
the last question which is
what do you do to keep things spicy yeah
20 years into your marriage let's leave
let's leave them with this the story of
the first time we bought vibrators yeah
how about that heck yes
hell yes
damn yes
get dirty you don't have to emphasize it
that much um yeah
well female orgasms are very important
yeah and let's just say that i think we
we did establish that those are
uh a a regular
okay let me i'll go as far as to say
um there's a book that i haven't read
that's called she comes first
and it and i don't i don't have to read
it to know that i abide by this
particular philosophy yeah so
uh once it's a guarantee for us but it's
not for them like you talk about yeah
they talk about the first time once we
figure it out once we figured out
what how to how the orgasm could be
achieved
that became something that was now
it is the priority and it is something
that happens
every time now maybe there are some
quickie situations every once in a while
in which it's very clear that jesse has
made she said i'm making an exception
right now that this isn't about me this
is about you and that's and that's an
understanding
but that's a rare exception so i would
say that the gold standard the gold
standard is to both have an orgasm which
means her having it first and then hey
sometimes you can you can work this
you get the timing right sometimes just
together which is
exhilarating
back
let's see you and i were traveling the
mid-south region working with crew and
we were speaking on campuses
for context that was our job we're
listen we're on staff a campus crusade
for christ an uh interdenominational
christian organization
working full-time for them so this is
this is when we're talking to students
about sex we're still in it we weren't
talking about sex we were still in it we
were talking about evangelism yeah how
to share your faith with your friends on
campus
and we weren't but we weren't prudes
about it yeah i i just you know well the
story is going to show though yeah yeah
yeah right yeah i'm just given the
context for we were in charleston south
carolina and we had taken a circuit to
get there so we had been gone for i
don't remember how long but it had been
a while and we had made arrangements hey
christy and jesse you guys drive down
and meet us in charleston because it's a
romantic city we can hang out number one
travel destination in the nation we'll
take it for some reason extra days great
but i mean come on i find that hard to
believe it's been like i mean like
shrimp and grits is good ten years in a
row quite human like travel in leisure
magazine or something some big
publication charleston's the place to be
don't go at the hot times unless you
want to create a hot time so we knew
that christy and jesse were coming into
town that night and we had each gotten a
nicer hotel room than we would normally
stay in
this is how i remember it
we had decided that day we were walking
around
town and we were like let's go
to
a sex toy shop let's go to an adult
store and buy
something get some to spice up
paraphernalia what's going to happen
tonight because we've been away from our
wives i think this has probably been
this was in the first couple of years of
marriage still he's still on staff it
was early yeah so we go in we go into
this place and it i mean it was
it wasn't an adam and eve but it's like
one of those a little more charleston i
remember it was like what there was a
gentle breeze blowing through it i don't
know why it was there was a porch there
was a porch there was a swing set
there was shrimp and grits
uh you gotta you know you gotta grind
those grits you know you just gotta
grind those grits
um
it was a little awkward perusing this
shop with you
and
what we didn't want to do is look at
pornographic
images on the packaging but there's
we're still a little scared of that so
we didn't you know we felt like that was
wrong so we were trying to we were
avoiding that but i don't know which one
of us found it but one of and because i
think we kind of split up
we were both perusing a little bit but
one of us found
a vibrator that was neon green
and it didn't have
a naked chick or a naked dude on the
packaging it actually had a doctor's
it was like it was branded by like some
sex doctor a gynecologist
and so it kind of had more of a clinical
beginner
dildo type vibe now that you're talking
about it now okay do you still have this
you guys collect everything you still
have this vibrator no we don't at a
certain point we just we've upgraded it
we used it we we vibrated it into
oblivion but it was about this long yeah
well how long is that for the listeners
uh i'm saying that's uh four and a half
to five inches right and it wasn't
shaped like a penis it was it's like a
worm it had like a grip christy and i
call it the green worm
we called it that because it might have
been what the name on the package was if
we haven't made it completely obvious
ret and i both bought the same vibrator
well two of them we didn't share it
you didn't like clean it up in fedex
monday wednesday fridays it's the neal
night with green we weren't making any
money in those days we probably should
have split it
it it was a battery-powered um silicon
undulated
um
landscape of pleasure
and yeah we called it the green worm you
bought the same one we didn't tell our
wives that we were doing this or that we
bought the same one
or that we bought it initially of course
the course
there's many times in life where one of
us has done the research on an item yeah
well the best tv is this one okay well
that's what i'll get the same tv we
literally the first tv we got as married
couples was the same tv from circuit
city same tv same vibrator keep it in
the family but you didn't call it the
green worm i don't think i i mean but i
did refer to it affectionately because
it became something that was uh we felt
very affectionate towards and we felt
very affectionate because of it well at
times i felt jealous of it here is the
thing that we also bought do you
remember we bought something else well i
don't but i'm gonna remember when you
tell me
sex masks
i thought it'll be a good idea to buy
like it's like a sleep mask i didn't buy
one of these you didn't buy one i don't
know what you're talking about a
blindfold man a mask a very comfy mask
that you that might be a sleep mask i
have one now
for sleeping no there's sex no i have a
sex blindfold oh we don't have one now
really we should get one
so my idea was
i'm gonna buy this and then and this is
this is what i this is christy calling
me right now
hey can i call you back we're still
recording the podcast talking about
vibrators
okay love you
she just said okay
so my plan was well they show up that
night we don't tell them that we've got
vibrators we don't tell them anything
and then the thing that i did was oh
it's like you know she's coming into
town this is well that's really you're
at a hotel you haven't seen each other
for a while
you're weary from the road and then i
was like so the way i did it
was i said hey i got you something and
she opened up this little bag and it
just had the mask in it and i was like
why don't you just put the mask on
and then
we started having some fun with the mask
on
and
then i introduced the green worm into
things and it was like
this may be a little too much juice fest
the mask came off and it was like what
the what the crap is this and then but
it was like okay so then we we uh
it was just an exploration in figuring
out oh what is this how do we how do we
incorporate this and it wasn't something
that we immediately knew how to do but
it was fun well figuring it out but it
but the mask wasn't really a great move
i definitely didn't use the mask but i
use the green worm quite a lot
and then subsequent worms of different
sizes and shapes
now
one of the things that i think for
context is that
jesse and christy which they didn't talk
about but jesse and christy had never
had their own vibrator right like it's
it's it's more commonplace especially in
like secular circles but also just more
commonplace today that like no sexual
urge was validated for them and it was
even i mean you heard their stories yeah
there was a lot more placed on them than
us but there was a very
interesting combination of factors that
i think
based on our stories kind of played
itself out in both of our marriages and
i'm grateful for this and that is
yes we were in this place that kind of
suppressed and attached shame
but the nature of our relationships and
the nature of our communication and also
the general openness towards sexual
experience and sexual exploration
is it a pretty high level amongst within
both relationships and there wasn't too
much
damage to remove us from having fun
experiencing those things so you get
this combination of i've never seen a
vibrator
yeah
speaking from my wife's perspective i've
never seen one of these i've never
experienced one of these but but not
coupled with and i also think it might
be gross and wrong and weird and awkward
and i don't want to do it right i've
never seen this but holy [ __ ] when you
turn that thing on new things start
happening things yeah things that i'm
sorry i'm i'm i'm just gonna be honest
with you i'm pretty good
right with my tongue
but i can't move it that fast
try eating a couple of batteries first
and so
the uh
eat a couple of batteries i do not do
not take medical advice uh from this
podcast yeah so we discovered hey this
is a tool that we can use within the
context of our love making and it was
something that we would you and i would
talk we would encourage each other it's
like
you know
unabashed passion for ex you know
enjoying
each other's our wives bodies and them
enjoying us was something that we
encouraged each other it wasn't a
one-upmanship but
it was sometimes it might have been a
little close to that in terms of like
we would share things that like hey how
are you using this thing what are you
doing what's your technique what speed
are you on we would uh don't get too
fast because you don't want to be
you don't want them to forget about you
we would encourage but we would
encourage each other to experiment with
our wives and have fun
obviously
talking about them and not blindsiding
them
well you literally put her in a
blindfold yeah but i didn't do that it
was very playful and it was kind of a
prankish kind of a thing that like she
was on board with that but
and as you look back over the course of
our marriage again this is just i
haven't thought a lot about this until
we started talking about it
but
you might be tempted to think that oh so
you guys had some weird views on sex and
there was some weirdness and awkwardness
and then you deconstructed and then you
like turned on all of a sudden there was
a
switch that was flipped and your sexual
lives became totally different right i
would say
the progression of my sexual exploration
and experience with jesse
uh has has progressed
geometrically
over time not exponentially i mean i'm
not
a superhero right there's been a
geometric progression over time of our
sex life getting better and the things
that we try expanding and like us
experiencing each other in different
ways and the communication has always
been very in lockstep and very vibrant
and there's been a lot of it
and the deconstruction
didn't solve a problem in that area
right uh and it didn't necessarily
intere it also very very clear about
this it didn't introduce new problems in
that area i think if anything i think it
maybe did give us
you know expanded our minds in a couple
of different areas but
i i not necessarily i don't necessarily
think that
it was exclusively because of the
deconstruction and i think that
we
it's just an observation that we were if
we had never deconstructed
we were still evangelical christians our
sex life was still
vibrant because what i'm trying you know
i i don't agree with purity culture i
obviously don't agree with evangelical
christianity i don't think that is true
but i don't want to also then try to
make an argument that people because
you're in an evangelical relationship in
evangelical marriage that you're not you
don't have a you by
default don't have a great sex life no i
actually don't think so you might have
some specific things that you might have
to overcome and navigate
but that's just not the case i think
that this the sexual relationship in in
the context of a
partnership marriage a relationship
whatever you want to call it
is something that's very dependent on
the communication climate and the sort
of the boundaries and the standards
between those two individuals and there
was just a sexual compatibility that we
kind of got lucky with because we didn't
know that there was going to be the
level of sexual compatibility that we
each have with our wives
but we had a strong indication because
it did for me an engagement it did ramp
up and i feel like that
really helped
set us up for success on our wedding
night that it wasn't like going from
cold turkey flipping a switch because i
don't know what that would have felt
like and i
i've heard the horror stories
from other people who years into
marriage still aren't able to be into it
i definitely aren't talking about it
talking about i just feel like the
community and that's the number one
thing for me is the communication
because
in every relationship and every aspect
of every relationship communication is
key and it just plays right into
the like the moment in the same way that
you can have some sort of weird conflict
that's going on and there's resentment
building and you're not addressing it
right you know let's just say you're in
one of those relationships where one of
the one of the people has halitosis we
talk about this all the time right
and it's just like okay are you going to
become a person that just is in a
relationship with someone who has
halitosis and everyone knows it
are you going to become the person that
says hey
you have
halitosis and we need to address it and
i'm sorry that it hurts your feelings
and makes you feel awkward in this one
conversation but together as a team we
can cure your problem it's not going to
be that hard actually we just have to
actually be on the same team we have to
recognize the problem
if you let that kind of like we're not
talking about this because it's awkward
if you let that happen with sex you
could go a decade yeah without
experiencing this incredible sexual
experience and again this may not be for
everybody one of the things that uh i
didn't even know was a thing until
you know my adult life was asexuality
right there's some people who are you
know don't experience sexual
uh attraction and
so
if there's a huge spectrum but i'm
saying that if you are in a relationship
and you are sexually attracted to each
other
but yet there's a huge block in between
you
and you're not having a satisfied sexual
relationship and it's not because listen
there are physical things there's people
who are in accidents or suffer from uh
some sort of complication or a disease
where you can't have sex right or maybe
you get old and it's just less of a
priority or whatever there's but i'm
saying that if you're physically capable
you're in a relationship where you're
attracted
and you're you don't feel fulfilled
and you're not talking about it the
first step is talk about it it isn't
just like hey i'm gonna put the
blindfold on and bring in the green worm
you can do that no don't do that but how
about just having a conversation about
it and that i know it's difficult but if
you
if somebody thinks
that it's going great but they haven't
sex is going great but they haven't
really talked about it and explored it
with their partner
then it could be that it's just going
great for them
you know i think that's something we
learned in at first it's like that was
not my recollection of our wedding night
yeah right uh that she would have said
it that way well i have since
yeah she's told me that many times since
then i knew that she was not as
satisfied as i was
okay let's leave it at that i'm not
gonna give a wreck i i gave jesse my
wreck in the middle of this thing with
the braille uh podcast
yeah where do we begin where do we begin
so next week uh now first of all
i don't want to make any promises but
there's still a lot left to talk about
maybe we'll bring back sex timber next
year who knows i don't know but what we
are definitely going to do is next week
is the finale episode of sex timber
where we're going to answer all the
questions that have built up
and hashtag your biscuits
so we put a prompt out on uh twitter in
a couple of places so respond to that or
just ask your question with hashtag
earbiscuits we want to know what it is
that you want to know and we're going to
answer it
talk at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best